we're second day members of Congress
slammed social media Giants were
allowing a Russian campaign to influence
and divide Americans executives from
Facebook Twitter and Google testified
yesterday about Russian ads on their
sites before and after the 2016 election
lawmakers released dozens of those ads
one senator called the Russian effort
quote the beginning of cyber warfare
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with
this story Nancy good morning good
morning we're now getting a look at a
wide range of those ads which were
designed to create divisions on a whole
range of topics including immigration
gun control and race and they were
viewed by tens of thousands of users one
of them for example called being
patriotic promoted a non-existent New
York City rally called down with Hillary
and referred to her as the co-author of
Obama's anti police and
anti-constitutional propaganda another
page united muslims of america created
an event at the Obama White House asking
to support Hillary and save American
Muslims but some ads focused on issues
like banning burkas in America or
defending the Second Amendment right to
bear arms these pages had titles like
black diva stand South United all of
them made up groups and they even
continued after the election one
anti-trump page promoted a not my
president rally rally in New York City
again these rallies did not take place
now many of these ads were paid for in
rubles through a Russian payment service
called kiwi and the social media
companies that testified say they are
currently working Nora on ways to more
easily identify who's paying these ads
and how they're paying for them all
right really interesting Nancy thank you
so much